今日は外れ社長ですぼく前このフィルムケースを使ってもうちょっとで
さぁさぁロケットを作ったんですけど
その今日はですね前回の件とはこうなって作業音手作業で全部できれば羽化させて
やろうといったけど失敗したんですよあれはもう大失敗
やっぱりドクター外れとしては何か失敗許されないです
なぜ今回はですねちょっと無数の
フィブロゲット準備したんでん
こんな感じです今度はちゃんと考えました一応このフレームロケット全部に5はお湯を
入れるとお家の方が反応しやすいって聞いたらお湯を入れて
遂げたよ入浴剤も全部準備してるんでこのふたの裏に入浴剤をつけてテープで留めて
どうすると思う
でもまだ反応してませんを言うというよく剤がくっついてないねまだ反応してないん
ですこの状態でまだ反応するときにこうしてひっくり返す
そしたら全部一気に反応するんじゃないかと
でね僕はねもう失敗したときからずっと考えていたんですけれども
ただロケットを飛ばす世界へ3個でもただロケット飛ばしちゃ面白くないんで
この一斉に飛んでくるとけど俺はでもうね同大視力がマジでもうスーパー e ロー系
なんで全部素手でキャッツしてね皆にドラので自慢したいと思います
準備よセレ女の木の下にねよくぞ4セットして
テープで留めますやだここでお湯を入れてこうして
一応設置完了ってことで終えが準備しなきゃっ
[音楽]
鎧
しっかり恋風止まります額は1
加え強い声は
wh
[音楽]
おっん
worth
ここまでうまくいっついて怖いんですけれどもこれ本当に大丈夫アップ行くかなぁー
失敗しちゃダメなんだぞ
the 今からこの発車内容
可部線って僕は俺の腕の中目線でもぐるっと回して全部一見発火させてそれは前世で
キャッチします
で際ジョブ本当にやばくねてがてが俺ん家大丈夫か
いやそういうのどうでもいい俺なロケットって言うな
寿命を叶えるためにやるしかないんだ
図録出されてる派
水21ファイヤー
うわぁこれ本当一発勝負だ fire とか言いながら怖くてできない
設置セット官女
ああ怖いこれシッポいるさえも頑張り始め
を前に日本の世界の未来がかかっている
ちょっとミスったかなちょっとミスったん
大丈夫なんとかよしってくださると思う
8枚まあこれちょっとマジかよ
ず郡山なんか
それ生まれたぞあ
ran
ああああああああああああ
dare
ママ
バードリームにメリー
バーガーどっん
前世
[音楽]
バッハ
とっん
はっはっはなんっ
[音楽]
マッハだったよあもう御本尊な
ていません
ちょっとません
全ツアー
映ってうわっもうもう大丈夫だよね
あ嘘一家も撮れなかったす
ってなんか母ちょっとなんかねえ
なんか自分の
可能性というか
なんだ
あのっ
トレイルートねぇ取ろうと思えば取れましたでも
ちょちょっとビビりすぎてああ
大丈夫だよな
も大丈夫なんだよねー
もう来ないよねー
無理なのよなんか何も信じれないもう
もっとないよねー
本当に
もう大丈夫マジ
いや本気で
ぞなんかサーバと身が飛ぶとかほんとやめてない
そういうの一番売れたかッ
あっ
はぁっ4
うん
me
uh
ああああああ